you
hi everyone is Jerry this is round 8
from the 2013 World Chess Championship
match between Anand and Carlsen going
into this round Carlson has a four and a
half to two and a half lead over andand
and Carlsen with the white pieces and
this one opens with E 4 this is the
first time he is playing e4 in the match
and we get to see Anand replying with
the right Lopes Berlin defense and we
entered the open variation allowing the
e pawn to be captured but blacks epon
will be taken right back keep in mind
this would be game over for black do not
capture on b5 instead develop Bishop e7
the bishop returns to a perfect square
on f1 on the back rank but you could say
that it is still developed in some sense
since the rook is contributing on the
open file the Knights are exchanged
castles d4 not a whole lot going on
especially with symmetrical pawn
structure as we will soon see it is
completely symmetrical on the Queen side
d4 prepares to develop the rook is
chased back not a better Square than a1
anywhere else could be kicked around in
some way the rooks are now in tension
with one another and with that last move
there was the threat of rook takes rook
Queen takes and then the win of a pond
so c3 is there to solidify the center
the rooks are exchanged the night now
retreats so that black can establish a
pond in the center and there is also
another idea tied in with this move as
we will soon see and it involves
exchanging black's bishop on c8 for the
one on f1 first Bishop f4 d5 and you
might think Knight d2 just moving
forward with more development but with
this last move black is ready to place
the bishop on a nice diagonal so keep in
mind we may also want to interfere with
the developing moves our opponent our
opponent is looking to make and this
clearly makes life a little bit more
difficult for the
Bishop buttonand addresses this quite
easily g6 axe is not only a flight
square but the knight will look to
fianchetto himself which would then
support this light square bishop
exchange and as soon as d5 is played
you'll know we could already identify
the good and bad bishops he's considered
bad due to the fixed pot on light he's
considered bad due to this pawn fixed on
dark but that really isn't going to play
a great role in this game because as we
will soon seen the structure on the
Queen side is perfectly symmetrical not
a lot going on there and soon enough we
have both sets of bishops being
exchanged and not much going on here one
open file nothing happening on the Queen
side ninety-five taking up a post in the
center the rook gets on an open file the
Queen returns home and there is just a
little bit of caution needed by the
black side here Knight g7 is played and
Queen takes rook was the follow up keep
in mind at night f6 while tempting would
be a serious blunder because of the
reply Queen takes Knight and if Queen
takes Queen this is game over black
would win but you don't throw in this
check at least right now you first
capture and before you know it we end up
in a position where it is stripped to
simply the kings and the pawns and soon
enough with the insertion of b4 and b5
the Queen side is officially locked down
no progress will be made there's no way
for either King to penetrate on the King
on the Queen side maybe there's some
hope over here on the King side however
king f7 h3 h6 and as soon as h4 is
played that's the big tell that this
game will turn out to being a drop after
the follow up h5 now it is both sides of
the board that is that are locked up
there's no way to proceed
no entry points for either King and it
is at this point that a draw is agreed
so keep in mind Carlsen at this stage in
the match doesn't need to do a whole lot
its back on Anan shoulders and probably
the last big try by him will be in round
nine where he has the white pieces so
after this game it does bring it to five
points for Carlsen three points for
Anand it's a race to six and a half
points we will get to see around nine we
will get to see around ten will we see
around eleven so that is of course to be
determined that is all for this video
and as always I hope you got something
out of it take care bye
you
[Music]